all right let's jump into this first
story we have this from tipcast.com
Kanye West to buy social media platform
parlor after being censored on Twitter
and Instagram hey good for him I was
just I this came out of nowhere was
there any any Whisper of Kanye West
wanting to buy any social media
platforms
what was it knee jerk because of the
Banning or had this been in the works
for a while I I guess man I want to make
a lot of people don't know this because
I don't know if anybody wrote about it
but we're going to talk about it sorry
parlor look I got no beef but when
parlor was issuing the release about
this purchase confirming it they they
accidentally copied every I'm assuming
what's every PR email and uh
there's just hundreds of people so I get
an email
with hundreds of other emails attached
to it and I get these PR emails all the
time normally what happens is you blind
carbon copy someone so you put all your
PR contacts in BCC so no one can see
anybody else but they accidentally just
carbon copied every one of their
contacts I'm assuming everyone puts
hundreds and then all of a sudden I
start getting responses people are
emailing me and I'm like wait what's
happening why is like who's this guy and
then all of a sudden I see a bunch of
people I know that are on this email
thread and I'm like yo parlor just sent
out the email addresses of all these
VIPs and high profile people to everyone
else so now we've got like you know
Charlie Kerr use a diamond and silt yeah
Fairbanks on it I'm on it Joey salads oh
yeah yeah I got the entire I think it's
probably every verified account who has
a parlor a through J wow I was included
on
yeah
users yeah that's maybe that's what it
is because it's not press reps it's
famous people uh some members of the
Trump family I saw in there wow Trump
adjacent people so I've got lot of email
addresses now well I guess all of these
all of these high profile people are
media personalities so yeah yeah
overlaps politicos and media
personalities look like so that happened
and uh they sent me an email apologizing
and so it's like you know these things
happen but this happened and I kind of I
was kind of thinking like this might be
like a big story because there might be
some people who don't want anyone to
know that they've been in communication
with parlor or something like that so
one one email from a from a from someone
said like they seem to piss I said
parlor really values our privacy I guess
and it was pretty little anyway
back to Kanye does this story matter
what
of artists especially rappers changing
their names and we're all supposed to go
along with it like now right I'm not
going to say yay I feel stupid saying
yay I'm gonna say Kanye like how many
names did P Diddy have like ten yeah it
was like every week that's my I just had
to get that out of the out of the out of
the gate but I also had a fight with P
Diddy well now they've had a big fight
yeah oh yeah the text well that's where
a lot of those comments came out of
wasn't it yeah yeah yeah but you know
what I love when Diddy changed his name
South Park really went for it do you
remember that episode where it's like
did he do it did he did do it
he didn't do it but then he changed it
back to P Diddy right now let's just
full circle back when I was a kid he was
Puff Daddy yeah yeah and then he was
Sean puppy Combs and then he was how
many other names since then it was a few
it was a few yeah it was a lot of meme
yeah I don't I don't know what that's
about but you know he can call himself
whatever I want the question is you know
look parlor was I I think parlor may
have been about to displace Twitter it
was growing so rapidly it was a top of
the charts everybody was getting on it
and they really had this momentum and
then big Tech colluded all at once with
a false pretext January 6 to just ban
them out right yeah yeah so they have
that poddler did have you know a big
impact but I don't know if it's there
anymore I guess Kanye is just making
sure he can't be banned from any kind of
social media he'll still be able to post
stuff well yeah he was he was banned
from of course Twitter and Instagram
because of his uh you know salacious
comments that of course he was making he
he's also being described by some people
as an artistic genius and other people
is just a crazy lunatic either way I
think there's going to be some exciting
changes coming to parlor it's going to
be interesting to see what he does with
the platform he he definitely is an
outside of the box thinker to say the
least he also was just caught wearing a
Satoshi Nakamoto hat he was just
debanked by of course JP Morgan and
Chase the bank of Jeffrey Epstein who of
course
he got debanked and then wore a Satoshi
Nakamoto right yes yes so obviously so
for those are not familiar that's a
Bitcoin that's the Bitcoin founder
exactly so clearly he's making a
statement about the banking industry so
so yet again you know some people are
saying he's just an artist just trying
to sell his records some people are
saying he's really trying to change
change things in societies it all
depends on what you really kind of think
of him as an individual but but you know
it's not boring
new life as well it could be something
entirely different afterwards and it
could come back well he I think that's
it right he did a lot of interesting
things in the sneaker industry you know
criticize him for his words but but he
at least changed things up and made him
a little bit more Innovative a little
bit more different a little bit more
artistic a little bit more out of the
box because we just continue to see the
same old kind of routines and I might
not agree with his statements but but I
still think crazy people should have a
voice artistic savants should have a
voice no matter if you agree with it or
disagree with it I think that voice is
important to understand where someone
truly is and censoring it isn't going to
help anybody I don't think he's crazy I
I don't think he's crazy like yeah he he
may be eccentric but he's clearly
followed very very specific logical
paths to become a billionaire and his
his net worth Rivals that of trump it's
like Trump's worth more but Kanye is you
know relatively close in terms of being
a billionaire there is however his
statements he made about Jewish people
controlling you know uh Diddy or Puff
Daddy I don't know what's the guy's name
is you know you know yeah
he made comments about that he made more
comments on another podcast apparently
he did an interview and they didn't air
it and then he did another interview
he's like I don't even know if you guys
are gonna are gonna air this because he
won't air my comments but he's made
comments about Jewish people that I
think are either he's he's speaking very
very poorly or he's just completely
wrong and has really bad information and
I think people people can be susceptible
to conspiracy theories when they read
things that are incorrect it doesn't
mean I don't think he's insane you know
I think he just he thinks things that
aren't correct or he's expressing
himself in a very poor way let me let me
put it this way or or he's expressing
himself in a way that galvanizes media
attention so he could sell his product
better to you so maybe potentially was a
big rift or something maybe maybe it's
just a way of just getting attention he
said something like repeal the 13th
Amendment right I can't something like
that wasn't there a segment that was
edited out of Fox News
comments yeah yeah with what the Tucker
interview yeah yeah she said some [ __ ]
about Jewish people I don't yeah he's I
think he was like saying Black Hebrew
Israelite stuff and then there's the
Tweet the Defcon Jewish people that was
crazy yeah but then he's also made the
comments about uh Derek Chauvin and
George Floyd here's the point they're
gonna sue him he he said something about
uh repealing the 13th Amendment and
everyone claimed that he was pro-slavery
he clarified what he meant was the 13th
amendment allows slavery it specifically
says if you're incarcerated it says you
can't be a slave unless you're
incarcerated or something like that like
and what he was saying is you shouldn't
be able to be enslaved for any reason
he's actually correct we should ban
slavery in all capacities but because
he's not he didn't speak very well
people misconstrue what he was saying
now I got to ask I don't know what he
could have meant by those Jewish
comments I think he's read a whole bunch
of crackpot conspiracy stuff and he's
believing some stupid stuff that's about
it yeah and there is something to be
said about how he has his bank account
closed and you're right Jeffrey
rapstein's wasn't and they even had like
a press release about why they weren't
going to close Jeffrey Epstein's like
back before even when there was red
flags and warnings and he was a
convicted person who hurt children right
but you know someone's words are worse
apparently than sex trafficking but no
no I I think there was also a
clarification on that specific story and
that he was actually debanked before
making those statements oh so so he got
debunked then he came out and made those
statements was it for the White lives
matter shirt then
um what did he do yeah I don't know
again like who knows here's something
else Candace Owen's husband is the CEO
of parlor that makes sense yeah so
that could be why it happened so quickly
Kanye knows Candace he meets George
farmer I think is his name and then
Kanye's like you need money for this
I'll buy it and he probably okay and
then he like it's a private company so
they just went sure let's let's roll I
think this might actually be really big
Kanye buying parlor might actually be
the bigger threat to Twitter yeah I was
asking if the story mattered but here's
here's what I want to I want to add to
this it's possible Kanye is famous okay
we get it he's got a lot of fans who
follow him because his story isn't just
about his music it's about a success so
there are a lot of young men that see
Kanye and they want to be like him they
want to be a billionaire now he's buying
parlor they're gonna go join it because
they want to hang out with Kanye the
media can say whatever they want about
him they can't do anything about it if I
was Kanye I'd be hiring a bunch of
security guards because he's got a lot
of people that are real pissed off and
that's it's dangerous out there man and
with Kanye owning parlor then it maybe
won't be necessarily like a right wing
social media you know what I mean it
might be actually just apolitical people
his fans that have no interest or aren't
even right-wing you know so it could be
a big deal if black Twitter moves over
to parlor then exactly yeah the black
Twitter leaves and Twitter's over yeah
100 and that would make it not that I
mean we see these alternative social
media sites yes we're glad they exist
but you know it's all right Wingers
that's always my issue it's like why I'm
not on gab and all these things it's
like I don't want to just talk to people
who yeah I would take the hate over just
blinding you can't control yeah you
can't fight you can't troll that's true
yeah the troll is the most important
part I mean yeah that's why I love
Twitter you know I'm like I get the
troll people people get the troll me
this is awesome
mostly like my Twitter is I'm I'm like
my followers are mostly in the joke but
sometimes they're not and it's weird
that they don't get it yeah like I've
tweeted a bunch of a bunch of crazy
stuff I tweeted like have you considered
spaying and neutering your children to
prevent overpopulation and there are
people following me being like yo bad
take Tim I can't believe you would say
this and I'm just like welcome to
Twitter dude I do not take this platform
seriously it is full of nonsense right
well that's autism and I'm autistic so I
can say that is it is that what I don't
know I think I'm just taking it so
bluntly and seriously oh I see I see
like not not understanding the social
cues yeah that's that's really crazy to
me that I don't understand how people I
I kind of feel like people are
pretending to not get that my jokes make
no sense because they want to have
something to be angry about that's true
too like the anime thing with Matt Walsh
he's like yeah so for those who didn't
see Matt Walsh Media Matters went after
him because he said what do I think
about anime I think it's satanic I don't
have an argument for it but you know
something demonic about it and then
everybody goes nuts and it's just like
these are not serious people and you
don't insult anime fans because I was on
the pop culture show earlier and I said
something like you know what constitutes
being
anime does it have to be Japanese or not
people got so upset they're like no it's
also from here and here and here I was
like oh my God yeah let me not even
bother these people it's like a whole
universe you don't know exists until you
kick a hornet's nest yeah and they all
come after you yeah yeah
I I my favorite was when Matt Walsh said
that the little mermaid should have
translucent skin and look like a
floating skeleton oh yeah and they they
said it was racist or something yeah
they're like he's racist because there's
a black mermaid it's like
and then what did he tweet he's like
they're mad because I'm defending
translucent he called himself a trans
rights activist for translucent
translucent yeah
you know it's like
like in a lot of ways we're on the verge
of the Apocalypse for one reason or
another but at least there's funny
things happening as we ride the the
gravity bomb down to you know the
apocalypse the downfall's funny yeah
and it kind of keeps getting hey what
else are you gonna do yeah be angry it's
just the collapse of you know
civilization
yeah yeah I choose to laugh yes always
you guys exactly thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there